- And thank you Priya for, and Ty for,
I mean what's already
been a great conference
and the beautiful location.
Actually Thomas did an amazing
job of setting up, I think.
Some of the things I
won't be talking about,
but that will be in the background.
And I'm gonna do the
science and humanities thing
by giving you a kind of narrative,
by talking about the physics in some ways.
And I'm gonna give a philosophers talk
by not asking sort of what
are the causal relations
in some particular domain
and how do we know them,
but what are causal relations?
And the reason that this is an issue
has something to do with the
way that physics developed.
So there was a time when causation
was thought to be the sort of
objective ordering
relation of the universe.
So children almost out of the womb
or kind of engaged in causal exploration.
We push, we pull, we
learn what affects what.
Early science was all about
discovering causal relations.
So how did we get to the point in physics
where we were wondering whether causation
was even a part of the
structure of the world?
Well the back history of this is the same,
is that at the same time
that physics emerged
in its modern mathematical form,
causal structure sort of fell out of it.
And this is what Thomas was alluding to.
So what Newton's theory, which was really
the first theory that we had in a form
that we would recognize as
a modern physical theory.
And what it gives us is these times,
these associations between
global time slices of the world.
And they tell us that as he said,
if you knew the sort of...
Sorry, let me back up a bit.
That if you know the total state
of the universe at one time,
you can calculate the
total state at any other,
but they're temporally symmetric.
So as Thomas said,
you can calculate the future
states from past states
as surely as you can calculate
past states from future states.
They don't have an intrinsic
direction of determination.
And they don't say anything
about bringing about,
they don't tell us that
some particular local event
brings about another local event.
They don't say anything
about the intrinsic relations
of asymmetric determination
between one particular event
between this event and that outcome.
They're nothing like the
sort of discriminating
local relations that we associate
with everyday causal notions.
So Russell writes his paper in 1913
where he says that causation
is a sort of folk notion
that should be pushed aside
with the advancing tides of science.
It serves an everyday, a
purpose in everyday life,
but we should get rid of causal talk
entirely in a mature science.
So fast forward to 1979,
so 61 years later,
and Nancy Cartwright points out
that actually this salient
position just isn't feasible.
Time symmetric laws will give us a pattern
of correlations among physical quantities,
but we need specifically
causal information
for deciding how to act.
So this connects nicely
with Samantha's paper.
So for example, if you're a doctor
and you notice that people
with fevers are cold,
so there's a tight correlation
between having a fever and being cold,
that doesn't by itself mean
that putting someone
in a warm tub is a good
way to break the fever.
In fact, we know that's not so,
and the way that we know that's not so
has something to do with
the causal relations.
We need specifically causal information
to know whether something
is a strategic route
to bringing about ends.
So causal info, what
causal information adds
to correlations is that it tells us
what are the strategic roots
to bringing about ends.
So this point that Cartwright makes
is largely accepted in
philosophical circles.
People are thinking if
causation isn't eliminable
and it isn't fundamental,
so it's not there in the fundamental laws
must be some sort of
higher level structure.
If we can give an analysis of causation,
there's, if we can agree what you say
when you say there's a causal connection,
people, then we can understand
what is the physics behind.
We can look to try to identify the physics
behind causal relations.
But it turns into a
sort of complete morass
because people are can't agree
on what the right analysis
of causal notions is.
So people in philosophical literature
are trading intuitions about
increasingly artificial
hypothetical cases.
Someone gives a causal an
analysis of causal notions,
someone proposes a counter example.
It's sort of the metaphysics
version of trolley problems.
Meanwhile, in the sciences of course,
other than physics, causal research
is sort of perceiving unaffected.
Biologists are doing experiments to see
what causes cell death.
Cell death.
Medical researchers are looking for
what causes Crohn's diseases.
Psychologists, economists
and social scientists
are looking at what causes norm change.
People are thinking in causal terms,
they're asking causal questions,
deriving causal conclusions
in practice in science causal hypothesis
or guiding experimental
design and reasoning.
But there's still this sort of prejudice
against using causal vocabulary
in the formal presentation of results.
Despite what Samantha says, so
I thought this was at least,
I mean I thought that there
was this prejudice there.
It's certainly something that
comes out in Pearl's work.
I mean, he's deliberately sort
of addressing this prejudice
because there's this feeling
that causal ideas are heuristics,
but the objective content
is really in the statistics.
So then along comes interventionism.
So interventionism, what
it does is it provides
an analysis of the
content of causal claims.
And that turns kind of
those informal intuitions
that had been guiding reasoning
into an explicit theory
with a well-founded
logic and epistemology.
The formal theory is
introduced variously by Pearl
and Glymour at all with
philosophical foundations
provided by Woodward.
Basic notion is causal
relatedness between parameters,
it's relative to a network
and a set of constraints.
So A, it's causally related to B,
just in case there's an intervention on A
that affects or affects
the probability of B.
As the name indicates,
the notion of an intervention
is a central innovation.
So an intervention is
an idealized experimental manipulation.
It's meant to be a way
of manipulating the value
of a variable independently
of its own past causes.
The intuition is that
you separate the causes
from the correlations by
seeing which correlations
persist when you intervene
or when you manipulate
a variable in a network
that you're interested and
that is supposed to capture
the idea that, so getting
a hold of a cause of A
is a way of bringing it about.
Okay, so here's the formal definition.
I as an intervention on
variable X with respect to Y,
just in case I causes X,
I access a switch for X
for, sorry, I access a switch
for all other variables that cause X.
Any directed path from Y,
from I to Y goes through X.
I is statistically
independent of any variable Z
that causes Y and that is on a direct path
that does not go through X.
So the idea is if you have a network
of correlated variables
and you wanna know what
the causal structure
of the network is, what you need to know
is which, what happens to other variables.
If you get a hold of one of
the variables in the network
and you vary it, okay,
so you manipulate its values
and you see which are the
correlations that persist,
you can see immediately how powerful
an idea this is for sort
of capturing the core
of the scientific concept of causation.
Any correlations with B that
remain when we intervene on A
aren't due to the
information that A carries
about other causes of B,
but about influences that pass through A.
So this idea is used to generate analyses
of allied notions, direct
cause singular causation.
The framework, the
interventionist framework,
has proven robust and enormously fruitful.
It gives precise and explicit expression,
expression to the norms for
establishing causal relations.
Implicit in everyday
practice where manipulations
or other kinds of interactions
that mimic them are used to
test for causal relationships.
It tells us what counts as
evidence for causal claims.
How one tests for causal relationships,
how to extract causal
hypotheses from statistics
in a way that aligns with
experimental practice.
It provides formal tools
or graphical models
for representing causal relationships.
And a calculus analogous
to the probability calculus
for causal reasoning.
So interventionists sort of
sweeps across the sciences.
It's embraced largely
by both experimentalists
and the theoreticians and becomes
a more or less accepted
standard in research.
So that's the sort of backstory, right?
But suppose that your an
objective bystander to this,
sorry, wanna go back?
Suppose you're an objective bystander
and you wanna know what attitude
you should take towards causation.
So put on the hat of the
biologist and a social scientist
or the medical researcher
and you might think, look,
causation has been completely vindicated.
Causal facts are real objective facts.
They're first in the order of
a of empirical investigation,
we can make any system we
like the focus of attention,
we test for causal structure
by getting a hold of this or that variable
in a constrained
situation, manipulating it
and then observing its impact.
Observing the impact of the manipulation
on other variables in the networks.
So seeing if there's a change
or change in the probability
of other variables in the network.
This is the essence of
experimental practice
intervening in the practical sense.
Of course it falls short
of being an intervention
in the big eye sense,
in the sense that it
actually breaks any ties
to past potential causes.
But we do our best to randomize connection
to suspected causes.
We can always be wrong.
So there's a bit of a gap between
what we actually observe,
seeing a response
to an experimental manipulation
and inferring a causal connection.
But that's a part of the epistemology,
not a problem with the ontology.
So we can release ourselves,
if you've got this hat on,
you can release ourselves
from the shackles
of speaking only in terms of correlations.
Causal relationships are
a perfectly objective part
of the fabric of the universe.
So here's what Pearl says.
This is larger his attitude.
He says, "I used to think that
probabilistic relationships
"constitute the foundations of human."
Oh, sorry, "I used to think
"that probabilistic relationships
constitute the foundations
"of human knowledge,
"whereas causality simply
provides useful ways
"of abbreviating and organizing
the intricate pattern
"of probabilistic relationships.
"I now" he says, "take
causal relationships
"to be the fundamental building
blocks both of our knowledge
"of physical, both of physical reality,
"and a human understanding
of that reality.
"And I regard probabilistic
relationships as
"but the surface phenomena
of the causal machinery
"that underlies and propels our
understanding of the world."
Okay, so that's one attitude.
But now you put on the
hat of the physicist
looking at this in
particular through the lenses
of Russell in 1913 when he
wrote that original paper,
you might have a different reaction.
So let's go back to the the
the physics of Russell's Day.
We assume classical world
and fundamental laws
of temporal evolution.
We embrace interventionism, moreover
as an accurate formalization
of the causal concepts
and the scientific machinery
that's built around
discovering causal relationships.
One might now reason as follows,
I understand why limited creatures
investigating in a piecemeal way, nature,
think in causal terms.
In most experimental contexts
we have a provisional and a
pragmatically motivated division
into the inside and the outside.
That is to say the system
that we're interested in
and the outside world.
And we know it works well
enough in that setting
to treat certain
experimental manipulations
as interventions.
But we know that strictly speaking
there are no interventions.
No variable is ever as
a matter of physical law
separated from its own past causes.
The content that distinguishes causes
from correlations is purely hypothetical
in the sense that it comes
specifically from the treatment
of certain experimental
interventions as manipulations.
So it relies specifically
on the idealization
that small eye interventions
that is experimental manipulations
that we make in the laboratory,
are interventions with the big eye
that is interventions
in the technical sense
that they really do break
ties to all past causes.
If we take seriously that
we are parts of nature,
then our actions on the system
aren't really interventions.
Neither are coin flips,
or random number generators,
nor any of the things that we actually use
in experimental cases and
treat as interventions.
What there is in nature is
the unbroken fabric of events
when we absorb our activity.
That is the activity of the experimenter,
the manipulation of exogenous variables,
the setting of knobs,
the coin flips, the natural experiments.
When we absorb all of those
into the fabric of nature,
we find that they are,
that nature is completely
described without residue
by the unbroken pattern of events,
correlations, but no causes.
So you would be perfectly
within your rights I think
to think that interventionism has in fact
vindicated vessel rather completely.
The association of intervention
with human manipulation
of variables moreover
is not an accident.
So I'm putting, I'm putting on a hat now.
So I'm arguing in this vein.
The treatment of our own
experimental manipulations
as paradigms of intervention
is a holdover from illusions
that our own actions aren't themselves
part of the law governed fabric of events.
It also moreover reveals the flaw
in Cartwrights argument against Russell.
Remember what she said?
We need causal information
for practical reasoning,
but that is only because
in that context we imagine
that our own actions
are coming from outside
the fabric of the universe,
from outside the causal order.
Pearl himself was very clear
about the logic of the situation.
So this is what he writes.
He says, "If you wish to
include the entire universe
"in the model, causality disappears
"because interventions disappear.
"The manipulator and manipulated
lose their distinction.
"However, science," he says,
"However, scientists rarely
consider the entirety
"of the universe as an
objective investigation.
"In most cases, a scientist
carves a piece from the universe
"and proclaims that
piece in namely the focus
"of the investigation.
"The rest of the universe then
considered out or background
"and it's summarized by
the boundary conditions.
"This choice of in and
outs creates an asymmetry
"in which we look at things
"and it's that asymmetry
that permits us to talk about
"outside intervention
and hence about causality
"and about causal effect,
cause effect, directionality."
Woodward concurs with Pearl on this.
He says, "The special sciences,
which are really the parts
"of sciences that are knee deep, neck deep
"in causal thinking are open systems."
He says, "Such systems are
typically only a small part
"of a much larger world or environment,
"which is outside the scope
of the inquirer's interest,
"but which can serve as a
source of interventions."
And a little bit later he says,
"Including the whole universe in the model
"leaves no room for intervention.
"Causal notions are not
applicable to closed systems."
So when we're investigating nature,
the idea here is that we put
a frame around some system
and we investigate it.
We ourselves are outside the system
and we examine the
effects of external input.
This is essential to experimental science,
but the frame of course is artificial.
We can always widen
the scope of the frame.
We can always include
more and more variables
in the networks, put
more and more explicitly
into the models.
Any exogenous variable
can be made endogenous.
And when we carry this process out,
this process of widening
the frame to the limit
we do away with the fiction
that we are outside the systems
themselves that we study.
When we do that, we find
there are no interventions.
We should kick causal structure away
as an understandable but
ultimately liable heuristic
pushed aside as Russell said,
with the advancing tides of science.
Okay, so I think Pearl and
Woodward's attitude here,
or mine when I'm in a
Pearlian or Woodwardian mood
is that, well, in some sense
that seems like it gets
things the wrong way around.
What we're really trying
to understand here
is the idea of the non actual possible.
Modal content, that is what
would happen if such and such
has its most direct empirical significance
at the local level where it's an induction
on an open systems response to input.
That's what our most basic
and secure modal inferences
in science look like.
And moreover, modal content
has practical significance
or practical implications
for the embedded agent who
needs to make decisions
about what to do and has
to know what would happen
if they did this rather than that.
At the global level, when
we push modal content
to the global level, both the practical
and empirical significance become empty.
Possibilities are what?
Wholesale alternatives to actuality
external to the world in
which we think and act.
Modal content at that
level seems degenerate.
Not the basic form, not
something that we should try
to understand the actual
kinds of modal content
that have practical and
empirical significance
in terms of, not what
we should take as basic.
Indeed the way we give imaginative content
to modal implications at the global level,
what the laws entail about
other possible worlds.
It sort of parasitic on our
understanding of open systems.
So we imagine God reaching down
and burying the initial
conditions of the universe.
We reproduce the choice
situation in our imaginations.
So I've argued these two sides,
these two attitudes that one can take.
Here's the sort of basic
logic of the situation.
Fix the laws of nature
and the global pattern of correlations
entailed by the laws.
There are multiple causal models
distinguished from one another
only by what they entail
about what would happen
if, per impossibly,
we could reach in and vary the the values
of particular parameters independently
of their own past causes.
Okay? And the per
impossibility, per impossibly,
there means in a way
that's counter to the,
to the physical laws themselves.
So there are two possible attitudes.
We can reject this sort of modal overlay
that tells you what would happen
if you could per impossibly
reach in and vary the
values of certain value,
variables independently of those causes.
We can reject that as sort of empty
and non-factual where
it goes beyond claims
about the patterns of
correlations entailed by the laws.
Or we can regard the
causal facts themselves
as basic and objective part
of the machinery of nature.
Treating correlations as Pearl
does as surface structure
and global laws as kind of what you get
when you carry the division between
an inside and outside
past its sort of domain of applicability,
where you think the
causal facts are the ones
that ground facts about global
laws and correlations alike.
So the reason this is
interesting is in part
because the division
between these two attitudes
sort of marks a fault line that
runs through science itself
between the sort of practical,
embedded, interactive view
of the experimental sciences
and the sort of descriptive,
detached global perspective
of the theorist.
And it's usually in physics.
So of course there's
plenty of parts of physics
that are engaged in experimental science.
And the philosopher, I should say this,
God's eye view is very, it's where the,
the meta physician finds
their kind of hospitable home.
So with this in the background,
I'm gonna do something that's
gonna look a little bit
like changing the subject
and ask you to think about
a simple mechanical model
of a familiar kind of system.
And then I wanna go back
and look at this division
from the outside.
So in the descriptive mode
and then look at it from the inside
in the decision making mode.
And I'm gonna suggest
that the reconciliation
between these two viewpoints
is gonna be sort of contained
in the relationship.
But because I have such a short time,
it's really gonna depend
on you sort of reading this
into the mechanical model.
So imagine a vessel floating
undirected in the water.
So if just a ship it's floating
through the water in a local current.
I'm gonna introduce a rudder
into this system, okay?
And at first the rudder itself
is just a part of the ship,
but I'm gonna introduce a knob
that's sort of mechanically linked
to the position of the rudder.
So the ship is kind of pushed around
by the local current,
but what the knob does
is it provides a way for us
to introduce a new mechanism
to control the position of the rudder.
So this mechanism is generic.
We can splice in anything
that we like here.
We could have for example,
a little metronome that
swings back and forth
to control the position of the rudder,
introducing a periodic
motion into its movements.
We could have it on a timer
so that it switches direction
at an appointed hour.
We could tie the knob to
the leg of a little dog
that runs around the surface of a ship.
We could outsource it
to a sort of control station on shore.
Whatever we like, we can
now splice in anything
that we like into the dynamics of a ship
that's gonna abide the
use of the knob control.
The position of the rudder.
Position of the rudder is
now an independent degree
of freedom that complicates
the motion of the ship.
It becomes a locus of
control that can be exploited
to steer the ship by setting its value.
So that in conjunction
with the expected value
of other observable,
other degrees of freedom,
it sort of produces the desired motion.
This is all a very familiar
sort of schema for design.
A smart designer who wants the ship
to remain on due course,
we'll know how to adjust
the position of the rudder
to keep it on the path
given the local current.
So let me spell this out
a little more explicitly.
We're gonna assume here that the dynamics
of the ship is effectively classical.
So the laws are local, they're markoff,
they're deterministic.
The way that the ship responds
to the local current depends on all
of the internal variables
including the position of the rudder.
So the position of the rudder
is not singled out dynamically here.
But if all of the other variables
are in fact fixed across
the range of situations
that we're interested in on the timeframe
that we're interested in,
then the only moving part is the rudder
and the knob that controls it.
So this is just a fact about the dynamics.
I said if we fix all of
those other variables,
then the position of the rudder
acquires a special position.
But we can actually exploit this fact
about the dynamics by
putting in place constraints
that keep the other variables fixed
in the setting that we
expect the ship to operate.
And by that I mean we can literally
like bind the parts of the ship
into a fixed configuration,
do what we need to do
to constrain the values
of those other variables across
the range of circumstances
that we're interested in.
The knob then has a special position
as the only under those conditions
as the only active
internal variable, right?
We can use it so that in conjunction
with expected values
of exogenous variables.
So wind, current temperature,
we can use the position of the rudder
to realize intended movement of the ship.
So how does that work?
Well, let's suppose there's
a little onboard computer
with a programmed destination.
The computer gauges the local current,
calculates where the rudder needs to be
to keep it on due course
and sets it accordingly.
So what do I mean when I say it calculates
where the rudder needs to be?
I mean that again, this is
just making a little bit more
explicit things that you already know.
I mean that it predicts
the expected values
of different settings of the rudder
and chooses based on the,
not the expected value,
the expected outcome of putting the rudder
in different positions and calculates,
and then bases its
decision on the assessment.
If we want to predict
the motion of the ship,
it's not enough to know,
as a matter of physics,
it's not enough to know the local current.
We have to also know the
position of the rudder.
The position of the rudder is being set
by this internal computational cycle.
So effectively we have to
know if we want to know
where the ship is going,
we have to know where the ship wants to go
and which way it should
go given the destination.
All of this should look
perfectly straightforward.
I'm just making, again, a
little more explicit things
that you already know instinctively.
So then we can use this as a schema
for a system that steers
its way around the world.
So the boat itself is a
purely mechanical system.
And we're assuming that
the laws are deterministic.
So there's no magic here.
The onboard computer is just,
the onboard computer is just electricity
flowing through transistors.
The high level design of the
computer directs that flow
so that functionally it
processes information
and performs computation.
The computational description here
is just a compact way of solving
the ordinary dynamical equations,
exploiting what we know
about the emergent
behavior of the computer.
So whatever you wanna say
here about the relationship
between hardware and software, say it.
Splice in your philosophical
views about this.
The system supports two
levels of description.
A computer is an actual machine,
so it's a mechanical system
that we can get to
perform any virtual tasks.
So we can, that falls
within sort of the realm
of computation by appropriate programming.
Okay, so now let's look
at the computational cycle
that the computer is running through.
So the ship has a single goal,
is charting a course towards
some target, location T,
and it has a single
degree of freedom here.
The position of the rudder.
What does the computer do?
What should it do if it
wants to reach its goal?
What's the right computation
for it to perform
in the service of reaching its goal?
Well, it treats the
rudder as a free variable,
calculates the expected effects
of different settings
given the local currents
and makes a choice based on
the assessment of the outcome.
That of course, is the same form
as what we do in practical reasoning.
We have more complex goals,
more degrees of freedom and so on.
But the control structure
here is no different.
So when you ask like
sort of what should I do
in a paradigmatic choice situation,
there's a range of available actions,
ways that you could set
the degrees of freedom
that you have voluntary control over.
You treat the action as a free variable
and you ask what would happen
if I aid, or bead or seed?
And then your decision
is based on assessment
of the outcome.
So the suggestion back when we were asked,
when we were talking about causation
was somehow that the
treatment of our own actions
as a free variable,
as an intervention in the technical sense
in the context of choice
is a sort of artifact
of illusions of agency.
The imagining that our
own actions aren't part
of the natural fabric or the causal order,
of not taking seriously, that is to say,
that we ourselves are parts of nature.
I wanna point out here
that there's actually
no illusion involved.
Indeed, it's precisely
because we are part of nature
that our choices appear
in this setting to us
as free variables.
And the reason is that
is because our choices
are set by the outputs of
those sorts of computations.
So let's go back and consider the ship.
And it is might help here,
I don't know how to do this,
to see this drawn out.
I want you to, ignore these.
I couldn't get a diagram that did.
So ignore those connections there.
What I'm assuming here in the background
as not represented in this diagram,
I'm assuming all of the scaffolding
that supports the everyday sort
of macroscopic environment,
so I'm assuming all the stuff
that that Thomas talked about,
I'm assuming a thermodynamic gradient,
I'm assuming the temporal
asymmetries that come with it.
I'm treating as constraints
values of variables that stay fixed
for the purposes of
predicting real time motion.
So the only things that are
explicitly represented here
are variables that change in real time
over the course of the ship's motion
and that matter for
the motion of the ship.
So six, here is the decision
that sets the position of the rudder.
So the decision here is
something that's going on onboard
that's happening onboard in real time
and is being done by the computer.
Eight is the boats, is
the motion of the boat.
Five and seven are sort of thing,
exogenous variables like
currents, wind speed, temperature.
Variables that in conjunction
with the rudder position
determines the motion of the ship.
And then just for simplicity here,
I'm going to elide the distinction
between sort of the
output of the computation
and the actual mechanical
setting of the rudder.
It won't matter here to make
that distinction if you want,
as long as they're highly correlated,
we don't assume that the
decision has no causal history.
We explicitly don't.
We take it for granted
that the decision does
have a causal history.
It's represented here explicitly
by all of these factors.
So here's the deci, here's the decision,
here's the rudder setting
and that's the ship's motion.
The only thing that we assume is one,
that the decision makes a difference
to the ship's motion in the sense
that given the other variables,
so given five and seven
and any other relevant
exogenous variables,
conditionalizing on six
has a probabilistic effect
on the ship's motion.
And two, that the decision
is determined by the output
of a computation that
assesses its effects.
In so far as there is a
line of influence here,
oh shoot, I go back for a second.
As there's a line of
influence on the ship's motion
that passes through the decision,
the decision will screen
those factors off.
It's gonna screen off all of the factors
whose influence passes
through the decision.
If the system is trying to
predict its own behavior,
it's gonna realize that there are
multiple consistent solutions,
depending on what gets filled in for six.
And that's where the freedom comes from.
Its own actions are gonna appear to it
as free variables.
So if you look at the
diagram, I'll go back.
If you look at the diagram,
you'll see that what, ah, sorry.
you'll see that what's happening here
is that you're making a decision about how
to set the rudder.
So you're making a little
calculation in your head.
You're sort of running a
little internal simulation
of a process that that
simulation feeds into.
So if you are trying just
from your position at six
to predict the motion of the ship,
there's gonna be a little
bit of self-reference
implicit built into the computation.
When you try to compute,
you're gonna hit a conditional branching.
That depends on the output
of the computation itself,
That's where the multiple
solutions comes from.
That's what opens up the space
for thinking strategically.
The system says to itself,
how do I use the probabilistic effect
of six on eight to my advantage?
How do I use the line of influence
that passes through here
to push the downstream probabilities
in a direction I like?
And to do that, it needs to assess
the probabilistic effect of six on eight
when six is treated as a free variable.
So it needs to know sort of
what the decision itself adds
to influences that bypass the decision
on the motion of the ship.
You can think of the process
between six and eight,
let me go back.
You can think of the process
between six and eight here
as consolidating all of the influence
that comes from six's past
and making a decision
about where to deposit that influence.
Eight of course, is just
one among the factors
that jointly determine
the ship's movements.
There's a ton of physics
that's going on here
that's determining the values
of these other variables.
So the currents, the wind speed and so on.
But the process is designed to effectively
hack that physics by determining
the expected values of those
and saying, what do I need to do here
to produce some target
state in the future?
So it's factoring them into its decision
about what to do.
So where is all this leading?
All of this is leading to the idea
that, look from the outside,
there are no interventions,
there's just the unbroken
fabric of nature,
but from the inside
there are interventions
simply for self-referential reasons.
It's an expression of the fact
that some of what happens in nature
is stuff that what we is stuff that we do.
And that's where causal
thinking has its home.
Teleology acting for EMs is
underwritten by the recognition
that decisions have an effect
that we can anticipate and
can be used strategically
to shift downstream probabilities
in a favored direction.
Whatever contribution your decision makes
to the determination of your action,
the contribution is
measured by treating it.
The contribution is
measured by treating it
as a free variable.
And you need to know
what that contribution is
if you're going to use it strategically.
So there's nothing diluted
about treating your own actions,
your own voluntary
actions as free variables
in the context of deliberation.
That's what creates the
need for causal information.
And this is, I think, the
right way to reconcile
that sort of inside outside views.
- Great, thank you so much.
(audience applauding)
We are running late, so I will,
how about two quick questions
before we break for a coffee.
- [Audience Member] It's a naive comment,
but I mean, I'm just wondering first
if there's discussion conflates
the difficulty of establishing a causality
and the absence of causality
fundamentally, right?
And so this is the first question,
and I guess I would just stand there.
- So I'm not sure why you say that.
- [Audience Member] Oh, okay.
So then to expand, say you have you,
you mentioned consistently,
continuously this fabric of universe
and in this fabric of universe,
say your talk is like a tiny spec,
and the question is
how those specs are
connected to each other?
The one possibility is
they influence each other,
which implies acquisition,
because the alternative
opposite of causation
is not correlation.
The opposite is randomness to me.
So then if the fabric is complex,
say if the fabric, the element is simple,
you can figure out what we
do in the laboratory easily.
If the fabric is complex
and the links are also complex,
you may just face the past situation
where you cannot define
what the causal relations
between those millions
and millions of nodes are.
But it doesn't imply by itself
that they're not influenced each other,
which the denial of causation would imply.
- So it doesn't deny that.
So the, you're, you're, I wasn't giving--
- [Audience Member] And
if it doesn't deny it,
then all this talk that
there is no causation
is, I mean, I would say empty.
- So the motivation comes from
being a fundamentalist
about the physical laws
and try, and sort of from a position
of the kind that Russell held, right?
So you say what they're,
what I believe in is fundamental physics,
and I'm trying to find a place in a world
that is fundamentally determined
by physical laws for causation.
So if you're starting
from the point of view
where you say, "Look, I understand
"why we reason causally and so on."
But that's partly because
of contingent limitations
and it's a convenient heuristic.
But what there is in the fabric of nature
is just what the laws tell us.
So, you know, I haven't given
an argument for that position.
It's a starting challenge.
It was the challenge
that I was starting with.
So in effect, it's asking for you,
tell me why I should believe
in causal relationships.
- [Host] Okay, Tim, quick question.
- Yeah, this is really quick,
but it just, it seems to me
you had on the screen in the middle,
there're these two attitudes
and that rises out of Russell.
- Yeah.
- It seems is just a false dilemma, right?
The options seem to be, Russell says,
"I don't see causation
in the laws of physics,
"so there's no causation."
And the other one is, "Well, no causation
"is basic and fundamental."
You wanna say Russell,
you don't see pianos
in the laws of physics either.
Okay? But they're real. Okay.
They're really real.
They're not fictive
and they're not fundamental either, right?
- No.
- So there are lots of things in the world
that are neither written
into the laws of physics
nor merely fictive.
- Of course.
- They're all the emerging things,
tables and chairs and everything.
So it just seems like a false dilemma
when you set it up that way.
Why can't causation be like that?
- Oh, okay.
- It's as real as a piano.
- Yeah, yeah, I understand.
So this is the way the dialectic went.
You start by think assuming
that causal relations are fundamental,
then you get the physics
and you don't see them in
the fundamental physics.
So then the back, I then the step backward
is, okay, so what are causal relations?
As soon as we have an analysis,
then we can understand the
physics that underwrites them.
People sort of taught, you know,
cast around for an analysis.
It takes a long time.
Interventionism comes along.
And that seems to, that
seems to coalesce people
around the idea that this
is the right analysis
for causal relations.
So how do we under, this
is the right analysis
of the content of causal claims.
What are you saying about the world
when you say there's causal relationship?
Analyze in terms of what happens
under hypothetical interventions.
And then look, challenge reasserts itself,
because you say, what is a
hypothetical intervention?
An intervention is something
that explicitly seems to go,
you know, is is counter legal.
It's counter to what the laws entail.
So that reopens the position
for a salient point of view.
So that's the way that the dialectic went.
I mean, I, you know, it
went very quickly and it,
and of course I ignored lots
of positions along the way.
But I really do think
that this is something
that to me captures the
heart of the conflict
between two ways of thinking
about causal relationships.
- Let's thank Jenann for.
(audience applauding)